emmanuel macron président de l'europe et
oui pour une durée de six mois c'est ce
qu'on appelle la présidence française de
l'union européenne et la dernière fois
c'était il ya quatorze ans alors on va
faire un petit tour dans nos archives
[Musique]
juillet 2008 nicolas sarkozy prend la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et comme le veut la tradition
il fait un discours devant le parlement
européen mais il se fait un peu secoué
par la gauche pour son refus de
boycotter les jeux olympiques de pékin
ambiance
vous allez manger avec des baguettes
avec le président de chine pour ouvrir
les seuls jeux olympiques
bon appétit
moi je penserai à tous les prisonniers
qui croupissent dans l'épisode prison
chinois comment dire à la chine aidez
nous à faire la paix dans le monde
assurer la stabilité dans le monde et en
même temps boycotter la chine au moment
d'un événement essentiel pour 1 milliard
300 millions d'habitants
quand on préside l'union européenne on
doit parfois gérer des crises
internationales et même des conflit armé
en août 2008 nicolas sarkozy fait face à
la guerre en géorgie pour l'indépendance
des provinces d'ossétie du sud et
d'abkhazie soutenu par l'armée russe
alors le président français montent dans
l'avion il va à moscou pour calmer le
président russe et puis il va à tbilissi
en géorgie et au final ils arrachent un
cessez le feu bien joué
j'appelle chacun
où qu'il se trouve
respecter la lettre et l'esprit
pour que les déplacés et les réfugiés
puissent retrouver leur maison
pour que les morts inutiles ça cesse
pour qu'il y ait moins de souffrance et
pour que dans le calme la communauté
internationale puisse apporter des
réponses à l'aspiration à la stabilité à
la sécurité et à la paix en 2008 les
crises internationales n'en finissent
pas nicolas sarkozy doit faire face à la
crise financière venue des états unis et
qui fait s'effondrer l'économie
européenne comme un château de cartes
alors le président français de l'union
européenne prend des accents
révolutionnaires face au monde de la
finance l'europe doit porter l'idée
d'une refondation du capitalisme mondial
ce qui s'est passé c'est la trahison des
valeurs du capitalisme
ce n'est pas la remise en cause de
l'économie de marché bon au final
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas refonder le
capitalisme mondial mais sa présidence
française de l'union européenne lui aura
donné une carrière internationale en
début de quinquennat à voir maintenant
si emmanuel macron va en profiter lui
aussi mais cette fois en vue la campagne
présidentielle
[Musique]